ecco io sono qui ci sono io che disegno
questo simbolo detto del terzo paradiso
questo è un simbolo che è venuto via via
maturando attraverso il mio lavoro che
comincia proprio con i quadri
specchianti poi specchianti sono la
trasformazione della tena in superficie
aspetti superficie specchiante in questa
superficie io inserisco delle immagini
fotografiche per cui abbiamo due
elementi fondamentali
uno è il movimento continuo il
cambiamento continuo delle immagini
nello specchio e contemporaneamente
abbiamo l'immagine fotografica che ferma
un attimo del presente che passa e e
muta nello specchio e quindi crea la
memoria abbiamo l'elemento di tempo
statico e l'elemento dinamico vedete che
questo questo simbolo che è fatto di di
tre cerchi appunto mette insieme questi
due elementi che io ho presentato cioè
la dinamica il presente che cambia
sempre nello specchio per cui ogni cosa
che noi vediamo nello specchio e lì solo
per un istante non c'era prima e non c'è
più dopo dunque è il cambiamento
continuo el'infinito l'infinito che si
realizza proprio nel continuo
cambiamento di qualcosa che non si fa
non si ferma mai è praticamente
il concetto stesso di nascita e morte
perché ogni immagine che immagine che
noi vediamo nello specchio in quel
momento e si presenta si presenta e
muore perché lascia il posto a un'altra
immagine successiva questo è il
movimento continuo del tempo ecco io e
siccome viviamo
diciamo continuiamo a vivere non si
muore ad ogni istante ma in un certo
senso però si muore si rivive in ogni
istante perché c'è una connessione
continua di elementi che fa sì che ci
sia nasca una continuità una durata
allora ho detto come come si può
rappresentare questa durata che poi ho
già tutto nella fotografia che fissa
l'immagine che sta passando dove fa per
durare il presente nella memoria
quindi io ho due elementi fondamentali
la memoria che che fissa il tempo e il
presente che cambia o questi due estremi
l'infinito cambiamento e il finito
allora come posso rappresentare partendo
dal concetto di infinito che è appunto è
fatto di due cd due cerchi cioè il
simbolo matematico dell'infinito e fatto
da una linea che incrocia se stessa e
forma due cerchi e questo è l'infinito
il punto centrale è il presente passato
e futuro il coach incrociano
continuamente puntando sul presente
allora come posso io siccome continua
vedermi nello specchio vedo immagini che
continuano allora devo devo capire come
rappresentare il finito cioè quello che
dura dentro tutto questo sistema che non
dura
allora fondo fatto semplicemente fatto
incrociare la linea due volte ed è
automaticamente nato un terzo cerchio
allora l'infini di due cerchi
dell'infinito si sono allontanati per
lasciare posto al al centro del finito
per cui noi abbiamo allora il momento
della nascita e della morte si
distanziano per cui c'è la vita
la durata la durata non è eterna la
durata è sempre relativa quindi noi
viviamo così come tutte le cose che
esistono hanno una durata non ha nascita
una morte che però durante questo
periodo di vita avviene una creazione
continua di fenomeni di connessione tra
gli opposti sono gli elementi opposti
che si combinano e che hanno sempre un
nuovo elemento che non esisteva e questo
è la creazione sembra un po complicato
però è così allora però diventa semplice
se si capisce che questo simbolo è
questo qui sia questa è l'arena di
verona
questa è la peste pettinengo dell'orto
del terzo paradiso questo sapete dove si
sono tutti terzi paradisi che sono che
sono nati realizzati nei posti più
diversi dance del mondo e questo è qui a
biella nella nostra sede e di questi
terzi e paradisio ne ho fatti ho fatto
alcuni questo e l'ho fatto io ma questo
per esempio è stato realizzato proprio
sul posto dalle varie persone dunque
dicevo che si è creato il terzo cerchio
tra i due certi che rappresenta la
durata la durata all'interno
dell'infinito dunque noi abbiamo
l'infinito prima della nascita definito
dopo la morte e abbiamo la durata al
centro che è quella della vita
un animale una mosca una persona
matteo su una materia qualsiasi anche
una civiltà dura un certo tempo e noi
abbiamo infatti vediamo le rovine le
rovine delle civiltà che sono passate
quindi la durata è una cosa
importantissima però però sta sempre in
questa dinamica dei rapporti i contrari
del prima e del dopo dell'infinito e del
del momento istantaneo che che sfugge e
la la necessità di mantenere questa
questa situazione che sfugge attraverso
una memoria
qui noi viviamo di di passaggio continuo
del presente e di memoria che noi
produciamo momento per momento per fare
per avere poi una come una vita una
dorata eccetera qui la memoria che cos'è
è un passaggio è qualche cosa che che ci
porta ci porta nel passato perché
qualcosa che è passata un avvenimento un
momento che è passato ma la memoria che
cos'è se non il futuro in quanto è
qualcosa che perdura nel tempo
quindi noi portiamo avanti la memoria
nel futuro dunque queste con
contrapposizioni continue vengono
rappresentate dalla dualità dei due
cerchi esterni la connessione la
combinazione nel cerchio avviene nel
cerchio in centrale certo interno e
quindi io ho messo a punto il teorema
della trina mica la dinamica del numero
3 la dinamica del numero 3 e numero 3
non significa 2 più 1 o 4 meno uno ma
nella trina mikhail il concetto è di una
universalità di questo fenomeno
il fenomeno che mette insieme due
elementi differenti e al centro crea
qualche cosa che non esisteva e questo
esiste in chimiche in fisica in tutti
gli ambiti fino alla vita sociale che
noi viviamo a partire non so per esempio
idrogeno e ossigeno da soli cosa sono
sono due elementi uniti creano l'acqua
maschile e femminile maschio e una
femmina sono due segni contrapposti
uniti creano un individuo nuovo che non
esisteva e la creazione positivo o
negativo
due segni positivo e negativo creano che
cosa l'energia elettrica senza la
connessione gli elementi differenti e
contrapposti noi non abbiamo
l'elemento terzo che è la creazione
quindi è latrina mica la dinamica del
numero 3 che vuol dire che 11 e uno fa
tre l'elemento centrale è il terzo
elemento è il 31 e uno fa tre
io e te facciamo tre dunque io e te
dobbiamo costruire le cose insieme
questa è la società visto dal punto di
vista sociale
abbiamo questa trina mica operativa
nell'interconnessione interindividuale
dunque non siamo più a livello di
assoluto di individualismo individualità
ma nella condizione della dualità la
società parte dal numero 21 e uno fa due
ma noi siamo anche duali personalmente
io sono sono tanto positivo quanto
negativo sul piano sul piano della
morale o etico io posso dire che sono
tanto buono quanto cattivo
quindi devo mettere insieme la dualità
in tutti i campi e poi anche
nell'esperienza della vita posso portare
questo concetto di dualità che crea per
ogni mia azione e posso partire dal
concetto che per esempio quando una tesi
questa è la strada giusta
devo dire sì però c'è anche l'antitesi
c'è la tesi opposta di chi si trova
nella condizione diversa dalla mia
ma è nella stessa mia posizione quindi
tesi antitesi devono portare alla
sintesi è la sintesi è sempre creazione
prima prima si è parlato dello spazio
bene allora questo questo simbolo adesso
è arrivato nello spazio
l'esa ente spaziale europeo con
l'astronauta paolo nespoli hanno
organizzato la lasciamo una un viaggio
di questo sito
di questo simbolo nella stazione
spaziale oggi la stazione spaziale ha
come simbolo in questo momento durante i
sei mesi dell'astronauta italiano che
sulla stazione spaziale e il simbolo che
ha portato come missione questo questo
astronauta
dunque cosa vuol dire questo vuol dire
che noi abbiamo sulla stazione spaziale
uno specchio uno specchio della società
perché è stata creata una app attraverso
la quale il il
l'astronauta che è nato proprio anche
come fotografo prima di diventare
astronauta fa fotografie della terra nei
vari punti mentre si gira pensiamo che
in un giorno
girando intorno alla terra questa
stazione non solo passa giorno alla
notte
ma le quattro stagioni il 4 stagione e
quindi proiettando questa immagine noi
lui mette in azione questa app che noi
possiamo raccogliere facciamo la nostra
volta delle fotografie e portiamo anche
dei messaggi che noi intendiamo far
conoscere e con il disegno con questo
disegno che è quello del terzo paradiso
noi abbiamo facciamo la fusione tra tra
il cielo e la terra tra la scienza e
l'umanità
la tecnologia e nel mondo in cui noi
viviamo quindi devo dire una cosa
conclusione che oltre a parlare di
scienze di tecnologia che che funzionano
comunque anche queste funzioni secondo
questo principio trin amico dobbiamo
pensare che c'è anche una trina mica nel
rapporto tra l'umano e lo scientifico
qui dobbiamo anche pensare che noi
stiamo producendo meraviglie e con la
scienza ma anche con la stessa scienza e
la stessa produzione artificiale
stiamo creando gravi problemi alla terra
di questo c'è più bisogno di di parlarne
di annunciarlo è stato annunciato in
ogni modo e quindi siamo siamo
responsabili di mettere insieme questi
due elementi che sono scienza e umanità
scienza e natura per cui
questi due elementi diventano essenziali
dobbiamo essere i nuovi umani del futuro
e non soltanto il robot del futuro
questa sono due minuti melegari
[Applauso]